[Music]
at the height of the Second World War
the Allied forces were planning a secret
mission to invade Nazi occupied Sicily
in order to confuse the Germans they
devised an audacious and utterly bizarre
plan a plan which hinged on the ultimate
success of one man a man who was already
dead on April 30th 1943 a Spanish
fisherman discovered the body of a
British soldier off the coast of Spain
the dead soldier had a briefcase
handcuffed to his wrist
the Nazis got a hold of the body and
examined the man in his possessions what
they uncovered astounded them the dead
soldier carried letters which described
critical details of the Allies plan to
invade Greece Nazi officials including
Hitler himself were convinced they had
stumbled upon the greatest military
intercept of the Second World War the
only issue for the Nazis was the dead
soldier in all of the details outlining
the pending invasion were a fantastical
ruse designed to foil the German army
the idea was conceived by a group within
British intelligence which included Ian
Fleming yep the guy who wrote James Bond
to pull it off the team have procured
the body of a 34 year old man who had
died the month before they gave the guy
a uniform a fake passport theater
tickets a picture of a girlfriend and
even loose tobacco to make him appear
real they drove from London to Scotland
and they put it on a submarine two days
later the body was placed in the ocean
where it was later found
Hitler was so convinced that he moved
the bulk of his forces to Greece in
preparation for the pending invasion an
invasion that never came so when the
Allies landed in Sicily they encountered
a whole lot less resistance occupied
southern Italy and ultimately changed
the course of the war thanks to one dead
man and a crazy plan
[Music]
once upon a time
what Wars about to happen but ones would
warn the soldiers were in place ready to
fight but a higher power made them stop
something unexpected and delicious a
warm milk soup our story starts here in
the Swiss countryside in Kapil and Albus
where our special peacekeeper dish was
created almost 5 centuries ago
legend has it actually let's get your
gunfire he's a historian for the
University of Basel and he knows this
milk soup so well
his even written articles about it the
Miller super is an elegant a hospitality
of in a conflict situation since 909
Atlantic India is very Italian the
católica on styrofoam isten chrysalis
and on turcica new person
he owns the scintillation site his foods
for petitions are divided in Italian an
understandin system after a while the
soldiers got tired and hungry so they
put what food they had together
the Catholics brought the milk and the
Protestants the bread and together they
made the legendary milk soup
[Music]
this halted the battle and a truce was
formed the suit became so iconic it has
a memorial in the battlefield and nearly
500 years later the soup is still
playing peacemaker from tomorrow and
this is Robert whose restaurant has been
serving the stuff for many years mankind
is Isabel him and when Hmong 1812 the
difference and hot items lost and meet
the freed leaf Anton Coleman does count
cells freaking super Benin and he makes
the soup the modern way with milk and
bread of course but also with butter
onions leek creamed vegetable stock and
some salt and pepper
let's make ceramic LifeCare they don't
like we as a firm do our life it hops
can so next time you're upset about
something with your neighbor do as the
Swiss do you bring the bread have them
bring the milk and have a bowl of soup
together
[Music]
World War two saw lots of generals
Winston Churchill shall de Gaulle
commander Eisenhower the one you
probably don't recognize is smokey a
Yorkshire Terrier and the tiniest war
hero of all time
I feel smokey and I were destined to be
together that's bill when a corporal at
the time and Smokies owner he bought
smokey for six dollars and 44 cents
during his time serving in the Pacific
Theater I think that if she fallen in
anyone else's hands she would never have
been what she was and she was remarkable
smokey followed the devil through 150
air raids twelve combat missions and
once even led bill to safety during a
Japanese bombing kaboom kaboom kaboom
well we look around we got eight of our
buddies all wounded round where smokey
and I were if smokey hadn't taken me
there I would have been standing with
the other guys
smokey also accompanied nurses on their
rounds at a US Army Hospital in New
Guinea smokey gets credit for being the
first therapy dog on record back in
Bill's hometown of Cleveland smokey
became famous doing tricks on TV shows
she could walk down a drum she could
ride a scooter
smokey died a celebrity in 1957 but she
wasn't forgotten she has memorials in
Ohio Pennsylvania Australia Hawaii
Tennessee but her biggest legacy popular
belief is that Smokies the reason that
your keys are such a popular pain
so thanks mochi the world war two dog
for all those cute little Yogi's you
[Music]
remember this can the sweet sauce the
soft noodle this twist childhood but did
you know that Chef Boyardee was an
actual chef he was his name was Hector
and he made a meat and pasta sauce but
it wasn't Hector sauce that made Chef
Boyardee the household name that it is
today
you can think the US military for that
in the 1930s
Hector BRD opened up an Italian
restaurant in Ohio and everyone was like
oh my god I love your sauce so he
started selling it and he sold a lot of
it a lot a lot by 1938 he had opened up
his own factory selling his sauce and
pasta
Cantus asked for Chef Boyardee spaghetti
dinner only about 15 cents a serving
then World War two happened and a phone
call was made
the US military called Hector had said
something like help make food for the
troops he already had the Kenyan
infrastructure so Hector said all right
his company shifted from a civilian
consumer base to a military one Chef
Boyardee became the largest supplier of
rations to US and Allied forces
production was happening 24/7 by the end
of the war the factory was too large and
the military demand no longer existed
Hector didn't know what to do so he sold
it to this large company called American
Home Products who were all like we got
this they quickly rebranded and
distributed the can as easy to make at
home meals and filled supermarket
shelves across the United States so
today when we buy Chef Boyardee we're
actually eating rebranded World War two
field rations
[Music]
in southern Pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the American Civil War this is
a story about that place it's also a
story about cats thousands in thousands
of little cats
[Music]
this is Rebecca hi I'm Rebecca and this
is her twin sister Ruth hi I'm Ruth and
we run a museum of dioramas that are
made with a hand made that civil war
cats Civil War cats the combination of a
childhood love for clay cats and a
strong fascination with the American
Civil War it started out as a hobby that
we just did as kids putzing around in
our bedrooms that bit of child's play
led to a full fledged museum which
opened in 2013
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale 1/8 of an inch equals one foot in
cat feet and so each one of our soldiers
represents one soldier who would have
been on the field will calculate the
numbers that would have been left in the
regiment and we'll fill it in with that
many cat soldiers so for example lower
on top we're going to eventually have
about 5,000 soldiers on it typically one
like the angle we figure took us about
four and a half years the Little Round
Top diorama we figures more of a five or
six year diorama we really just want to
make the Civil War more approachable I
guess for people so they can relate to
the history and have more of a
connection with the men and the women
involved now that the word of this cat
museums out all the people who love cats
come in and now not only are they seeing
our dioramas are following a love with
the five and a half thousand little
furry smiles smiling at them but they're
also learning the stories and suddenly
they have an appreciation of Gettysburg
and the history just because they came
to see the cats
[Music]
tootsie roll seems simple enough that
piece of gooey chocolate wrapped up in a
perfect little bite but believe it or
not these tasty treats save the lives of
US Marines in the Korean War in 1950 at
the North Korean Chosun reservoir US
Marine troops were engaged in battle the
Marines are running out of ammunition
and called for an airdrop of 16
millimeter mortar rounds codename for
these bullets tootsie roll when the
supply is fell from the sky troops were
surprised to find boxes filled with the
actual candies bullets this fluke turned
out to be a blessing in disguise
freezing cold temperatures had cracked
vehicle fuel lines leaving troops
stranded and although the candies were
frozen they softened easily in the
mouths of servicemen
Marines quickly realized they could melt
the candies down to a putty and seal the
broken pipes good as new when the
chocolate read froze they were able to
drive to safety in their newly
functional vehicles the Marines who
successfully escaped the reservoir admit
that tootsie rolls had a big hand in
their survival and they call themselves
the chosen few I'd call that a pretty
sweet victory
you